και κάπου χάνονται κοιταξετούτον το τελευταίο εναρχίσω από το τελευταίο δεν υπάρχει κυβέρνησης τον κόσμον
που να μην έχει αυτό το παράπολον κάνομε πάρα πολλα πράγματα λλα δεν μπορούμε να
ταυγάλούμε προςτα έξω η καλαοι άλλη κλασηκύρώ της τς ένα πολιτικώ εναι πέστε μας τουλάχι
στον ένα μειον έκτημα που έχει κυβέρνησης σας και είναι ακριβώς αυτόν ότι δυσκολευκό της
κολεγόμαστε στο επικίνω ι ακό λα βγάλουμε προς τα εξωτεργ που κάνου θεωρώ ότη το
κορυφεον πρόβλημα του για του νίκου χριστο δουλίδι κη προσωπικά και της κυβερνησης είναι ότι
προσπάθον πάρα πολύ κάνουν πάρα πολλά πράγματα μέσα σενανοικωσίτετράο εκεί άνο πρόεδρος τιςς δηποκρατείας μέσα
σε μιαν ημέρα έχει πένται οι έξι διαφορετικές δραστηριότητοχάνονται ναι δεδεες δε δυνιστην ευκαιρία στο
μέσον πολύ της το ψυφοφορών να εστιάσει στο ένα στο σημαντικό στο μήνυμα που θέλεις
να υγαλιστό των εντο έτο δεύτερο νομίζω που εχάνει και να από την πρώτην ημέρα
ανάλειψης της εξτουσίας είναι αυτή που έχει λγά υπαλλε με την υπερπροσπάθεια ιτάσει του προεύρο
τις δημοκρατίες να βάζει τον πύχει ψηλά στην τελευταία διέκανα λεγί πρέπει να πούμε ότι
τουλάχιστον το αναγνωρίζει ως πρόβλημα όχιος πρόβλημα το αναγνωρίζει ως κάτι που γίνεται απλώς ο
ίδιος θεωρί όται το βάζεψηλά και περνά από πάνω νομίζω ότι είπε περιπτώσεις τις οποίες
πέρασε πάνω από τον υπήχι μπορεί να έχουν να κάμουν με ζητήματα εξωτερικής πολιτικής όπως
ανέφερες προηγουμένος στα ζητήματα σωτερικής πολιτικής δεν είναι πολύ πιστικών επιχείρημα ότι περνούν πάνω από
τον πι και παραντόχρονα εναντελευταίον αφήνουν μικρά ζητήματα που δεν έχουν καμία σχέση με την
πολιτική αλλά εν πια σαρεικα εν κουτσον πολύ στικά τα αφήνουν να σέρνονται στην επικαιρότητα
για πάρα πολύκερο άραεσιανίσως σήμερα δήπλα από τον ίκο χριστοδολίδης ανεπικαινών οιολόγος σύμβολος επικαιρωνίες θα
το έλέγεαπό τα